أنت تشاهد عملية جراحية لحسن البالغ من العمر 35 عامًا،
يعاني من كسرين
في عظم الفخذ،
هؤلاء الأطباء يعملون باهتمام
لتثبيت العظام،
فقط شاهد هذا ربما لا يمكنك
معرفة مكان إجراء هذه العملية بالفعل
فقط لإعطائك  فكرة أننا في خيمة
في وسط موقف للسيارات خارج
المستشفى في منطقة الزلزال وأنهم
يقومون بإجراء جراحة العظام هنا،
نعم هذه هي
الطريقة التي تفعل بها
هذا، الدكتور جريج هيلورث،
جراح العظام من ولاية إنديانا الذي طار في
أقرب وقت  نظرًا لأنه سمع عن الزلزال
في الوقت الحالي، يشعر الدكتور هيلوورث بالقلق بشأن
النزيف، لذا هنا في جزء آخر من
الخيمة، وجدوا
شقيق حسن متطابقًا وجعلوه
متصلاً ويتبرع سريعًا
بأخ من الدم الحقيقي
وسط طبيعي  كارثة
تفعل كل ما يلزم لإنقاذ حياة
ما الذي كان سيحدث لشخص مثله
إذا لم يخضع لهذه العملية لقد
عملت في أماكن من قبل حيث
لا يقوم أشخاص مثل هذا بإجراء
العملية وهم يرقدون في المنزل يعانون من بعض
سيصابون بقروح الفراش وتجلطات الدم والالتهاب الرئوي
وربما يموتون بسبب ذلك قبل
الزلزال. من المحتمل أن يكون حسن قد
أجرى عمليته هنا في هذا
المستشفى في أنطاكيا بجنوب تركيا، لا يزال
قائمًا من الخارج نعم
ولكنه مدمر تمامًا من الداخل ولم يعد
يعمل، لقد تم تدمير هذا المستشفى  لذلك
لا يوجد مكان آخر لطلب الرعاية، فالأمر
لا يتعلق فقط بالعظام المكسورة
وإصابات السحق، بل يتعلق بهؤلاء المرضى
أيضًا، كما تمثل سلسلة التوريد تحديًا حقيقيًا،
وهذا هو الفريق من Samaritan's Purse،
إليوت 10 بيني، وهو طبيب طوارئ من
ولاية كارولينا الشمالية كان لدينا  هزات ارتدادية بقوة
5.0 وتتأرجح الخيام ذهابًا
وإيابًا وتضرب الأشياء ولكن لا يوجد شيء
كبير، لذا لا يزال من الممكن إنجاز كل العمل الذي يتعين عليك القيام به،
نعم على مدار 36 ساعة فقط، قاموا
بنصب كل هذه الخيام وإعداد المولدات
وأطباق الاتصالات حتى جلبوا
لدينا أجهزة تنقية المياه الخاصة بهم، نستخدم هذه
الآلة هنا لآلة التناضح العكسي،
فهي تسمح لنا بالحصول عليها من أي مكان
بما في ذلك المحيط وتحلية المياه
إذا أردنا ذلك، ثم احتفظ بها
في هذه المثانات وهي قيد الاستخدام،
إذن هذه تبدو  ممتلئ لذا فإن هذه
عملية تحدث باستمرار كل
هذا حتى يتمكنوا من تقديم أفضل
رعاية لمرضاهم
مثل ماموث البالغ من العمر عامًا واحدًا وأمه
سالسان ملتصقة بجانبه تحكي لنا
قصتها من خلال مترجم وما كان
حدث له
أنه لم يعد يستطيع التنفس،
اعتقدت أنه مصاب بالأنفلونزا في الأيام القليلة الماضية
ولكن الأمور ازدادت سوءًا هذا الصباح
ربما بسبب الأبخرة كما كان يفعل الكثير من الناس، حيث
كانوا يحرقون البلاستيك للتدفئة، وتم
تشخيص التهاب الشعب الهوائية والربو
الشديد  تم وضعه على غازات التخدير لفتح
مجاريه الهوائية وإبقائه على قيد الحياة.
حسن على قيد الحياة أيضًا ويتعافى
بدم أخيه الذي يوفر الرعاية
بالإضافة إلى الدعاء الذي يمنح هؤلاء المرضى
الأمل ويدمر المجتمع بأكمله
بالخسارة شريان الحياة.